[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon la Sicilienne nashdorf aujourd'hui
l'ouverture avec 6 fou C4 armes très
dangereuse arm très tranchante pour
analyser cette ouverture nous avons la
présence de Stéphane Laborde bonjour
Stéphane bonjourois cette variante avec
fou C4 qu'est-ce que tu peux nous en
dire bah c'est la variante fétiche de
Fisher Bobby Fisher champion du monde en
72 qu' a utilisé maint et maintes fois
et il avait de ses propres idées sur
cette variante avec les Noirs aussi
d'ailleurs avec les Noirs aussi puisque
Bobby Fischer était un très très grand
joueur de
nashdorf également donc il avait choisi
son arme pour affronter sa propre
défense c'est toujours un petit dilemme
chez un joueur et il avait donc choisi 6
fou C4 arme d'attaque arme très très
forte très très efficace très très
rapide surtout donc tout de suite action
avec des parties choisies des parties
commentées et surtout nous allons vous
conseiller une variante pour les Noirs
une variante assez intéressante cela dit
alors tout de suite les chiquers c'est
parti nous allons vous détailler les
premiers coups les blancs vous attaquent
car rappelons-le vous avez les Noirs
vous jouez C5 la Sicilienne donc jusque
là Stéphane rien de N r nouveau sur le
soleil cavalier F3 D6 le coup qui vous
permettra de jouer à nashdorf donc on
rappelle pour ceux qui ne l'auraient pas
encore assimilé que si on joue Caval C6
coup qui a l'air plus naturel et bien on
perd énormément en souplesse et on ne
peut plus jouer la nashdorf puisque
l'idée de la nashdorf et de ne pas
mettre le cavalier en C6 enfin une des
idées D6 D4 CCEN ouverte pu on prend
des4 4 qui prendre des
46 normal on attaque le 4 A6 et c'est là
Stéphane au 6e coup que les Blancs ont
le plus de choix possible alors on va
rappeler en quelques lignes quels sont
les choix blancs dans cette position il
y en a vraiment
beaucoup donc il y a effectivement ce
coup fou C4 il y a aussi le coup fou E3
qu'on a déjà déjà mentionn observer il y
a également le coup F4 qu'on regardera
plus tard donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de choses il y a aussi le coup G3 qui
est possible tous les coups sont
possibles dans cette position mais un le
coup qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui donc
évidemment il y a la principale avec fou
G5 l'autre coup majeur c'est le coup 6
fou C4 l'idée de ce coup Stéphane et
bien tout simplement le Fou est en C4 et
fou tout à fait donc en règle générale
nous n'allons jamais jouer avec E7 E5
dans cette variante puisque le fou C4
serait trop bien placé il faut donc en
toute logique jouer avec E6 donc ça
c'est la première chose quelle est
l'idée générale des blancs après fou C4
il y en a une il a un plan d'attaque
simple Stéphane qui est assez dangereux
mais forcer les Noirs à jouer 6 oui dans
un premier temps et ensuite essayer de
pilonner ce pion E6 en jouant F4 puis F5
voilà amener un pion en F5 mettre la
pression sur le pion E6 essayer de le
provoquer à prendre en F5 ou à avancer
en E5 et ensuite le fou donc qui sera
reculé sur la diagonale sur cette grande
diagonale et bien sera extrêmement fort
puisquil y a plus de P 6 la case D5 sera
complètement prise par les pièces
blanches voilà donc le plan d'attaque
général les blancs ça passe par F4 F5
mais il on a d'autres il y a d'autres
possibilités pour les blancs donc nous
allons tout de suite vous recommander
une stratégie à adopter avec les Noirs
dans un premier temps le coup E6
Stéphane c'est une nécessité c'est
important puisque le pion F7 est est
faible quand même il peut susceptible
d'être attaqué des sacrifices de fou
sont possibles oui donc il faut faire
attention dans cette position les blancs
peuvent jouer normal avec petit rock
tout de suite ils choisissent dans cette
partie qui est donc une partie Nigel
short qui est un fervant défenseur de ce
coufou C4 contre Kasparov qui lui est un
adepte de la nashdorf fou B3 c'est le
coup le plus généralement joué dans
cette position un coup tout à fait
classique puisque de toute façon les
Noirs vont quand même jouer B5 coup
intéressant puisque ça gagne de l'espace
à l dame ça permet de développer le fou
C8 en B7 et ça permet aussi de jouer B4
donc les blanc 10 je joue fou B3 avant
que tu joues B5 en fait ça ne change pas
grand chose ouais les noir c'est ça leur
est égal ils continuent leur plan il7 B5
alors menace tout de suite B4 attaquant
le cavalier C3 et laissant le P4 en
prise alors il va falloir se méfier Stan
ouais parce que cette manœuvre donc B4
le cavalier bouge et ensuite on prend le
pion E4 est très très dangereuse il faut
il faut bien vous mettre en garde ce
pion ne sera que très très rarement
prenable ça sera juste dans certains cas
d'école donc première bon ce qu'il faut
dire dans cette position effectivement
B4 est une des idées des blancs mais ça
peut être avec l'idée de jouer B4 puis
E5 une fois que le cavalier n'est plus
en C3 puisque il peut plus aller sur la
ce D5 il y a beaucoup d'idées ici les
Blancs ont plusieurs coups donc on perd
pas de temps à jouer à 2 à 3 les blanc
jouent pas à 2 à 3 les blanc jou pas à 3
puisqu'il aurait fou B7 qui tout de
suite attaquerait le pion4 et forcerait
vraisemblablement les blancs à jouer
avec F2 F3 et à ce momentl il jouent
plus avec F4 quand ils ont jou F3 donc
ça c'est très important si vous pouvez
éviter que les blanc jouent F4 bien ils
n'auront tout simplement pas d'attaque
et on rappelle les plans classiques si
les Blancs ne font rien Stéphane il y a
une case clé dans cette position c'est
la case C4 et donc on a plus qu'à
transférir le cavalier comme ceci vers
la case C4 ça c'est dans l'hypothèse qui
n'est pas inenvisageable où les blancs
déciderai de jouer avec F3 et donc se
fermerai les options d'attaque avec F4
F5 donc en gros pour résumer si les
Blancs ne font rien et bien vous vous
allez faire quelque chose amen le K B8
sur la ce C4 ça c'est un plan évidemment
il y a F et PE il faut pas négliger le
développement dans les ouvertures ici an
joue petit short petit ETP dans cette
position ne joue pas B4 et C prend4 qui
est extrêmement dangereux ouais pourant
ça a l'air in intessant on va on va
quand même le regarder
B4 en toute logique les blancs viennent
sur la case A4 cavalier prend4
maintenant4 ou et ici je il y a des
problèmes il y a des problèmes dans dans
beaucoup de beaucoup de cas je sais que
les Blancs ont perdu quand même un temps
de développement et les blancs peuvent
en profiter notamment peut-être profiter
de la case B6 qui affaibli le cavalier
peut Saer sur C B6 en jouant peut-être
fou E3 fou E3 c'est un coup tour1 est un
coup d'attaque majeur également puisque
les noirs n'ont toujours pas roquet donc
il y a des parties joué sur ce thème en
tout cas c'est c'est jouable mais c'est
très c'est tendu c'est jouable mais on
vous le déconseille puisque les blancs
sont complètement sur leur terrain le
joueur qui joue fou C4 contre vous et
bien il connaît ça il a des idées contre
ce sacrifice de pion et en général il
vaut mieux ne pas aller le chercher tout
simplement c'est pas une bonne idée fou
7 coup tout à fait normal on se dit
peut-être je le prendrai plus tard alors
dans cette position il y a plusieurs
plein de possibilités il y a notamment
F4 qui est possible ouais F4 avec idée
F5 intéressant coup direct et l'autre
idée c'est le coup de dame F3 qui est le
coup principal dans cette position
l'idée c'est de passer la dame en G3
d'abord ensuite elle attaquera le pion
G7 et ensuite de jouer F4 F5
éventuellement ou alors des attaques
avec fou H6 si les Noirs ont requé alors
au passage une petite menace les blancs
menacent de jouer peut-être 45 il le
menaceent certainement Stéphane puisque
après E5 on voit que la dame F3 attaque
la tour à 8 et le pion attaque le
cavalier exactement donc pour cela il y
a beaucoup coup de solution avec les
Noirs le coup principal dans cette
position c'est Dame C7 mais nous vous
recommandons un autre coup qui a été le
choix de Gary Kasparov c'est de jouer le
coup dame
B6 alors dame B6 c'est pas tout à fait
pareil puisque normalement la dame on la
met en C7 puisqu'elle est bien placée en
C7 elle risque pas de se faire attaquer
et les Blancs n'ont pas le coup fou3
enfin il y a une idée derrière dam B6
première pointe ça attaque le C D4 et si
les blancs dans cette position jouent au
5 Stéphane nous jouons d'abord fou B7
fou B7 puisque la dame en B6 contrôle la
C B B7 et après on bouge le cavalier
fou3 on prend le pion très logique
contre menace donc nouvelle menaceon
voit le fou qui attaque la dame la dame
qui attaque la tour donc là menace
cavalier pr ou cavalier PR5 ou cavalier
F toutes les découvertes de cavalier
c'est sur le principe d'une attaque à la
découverte doncès qu'on bouge le caver
fou Atta la D c'est inacceptable et
maintenant joue dame B7 alors quand on
voit ça Stéphan on se dit qu'est-ce
qu'il fait casparov ouais mais ça c'est
alors l'idée c'est d'attaquer le pion E4
je pense c'estd que la dame
effectivement attaque le pion4 avec le
cavalier F6 et on n pas bougé le fou C8
qui continue à contrôler la case E6
voilà ça c'est très très important c'est
que le fou on n pas toujours envie de le
mettre en B7 à cause de sacrifice
potentiel sur le pion6 et d'ailleurs on
peut y revenir bien avant après le coup
dame F3 dans cette position sur fou B7
et bien fou B7 serait une faute
puisqu'il y aurait fou PR 6 il y aurait
peut-être fou PR 6 ouais toutit s aucun
doute pr c'est un coup très fort dans
cette position en tout cas très
intéressant parce que ça prend au moins
ça prend TR pions cavalier prend la dame
doit bouger le cavalier va prendre le
pion G7 avec échec la le RO n plus de
défense exactement plus de défense
sacrifice thématique et ici ça gagne en
ligne donc c'est une des idées F3 on
joue d B6 on garde notre3 et d B7
maintenant attaque le P 4 le fou c comme
tu l'as dit stph garde le contrôle du
plus de sacrifice de ce côtél et
maintenant nous regardons d G3 assz
logique attaque le P G7
B4 contre-attaque contre-attaque
puisquon attaque le K C3 sur dame pr G7
on jouerait tour G8 tour G8 avec la tour
qui attaque le pion G2 et la dame en
embuscade voilà ensite on a plus qu'à
prendre le cavalier bon tout simplement
cavalier A4 maintenant on peut prendre
ce pion4 mais c'est toujours extrêmement
d mais surtout que enfin le pion G7 est
toujours en prise quand même faire
attention exactement c'estd si on prend
de la dame il y a cavalier B6 qui est
très ennuyeux si on prend du cavalier il
y a dame prend G7 qui est extrêmement
redoutable ouis parce qu'on peut plus
jouer tour G8 quand le cavalier en E4
donc dans cette position nous jouons
très simplement cavalier BD7 donc on
laisse le pion G7 en prise on laisse le
pion G7 en prise mais on pas peur non
puisque dans cette position sur dame
prend G7 on joue tour on jouerit tour G8
tout simplement tour G8 et après dame H6
dame prend E4 probablement qui menace
mat en G2 exactement avec une excellente
position pour les Noirs puisqueau coup
d'apprès on va jouer dam G6 sans doute
échanger les dames reprendre du pion h
une structure de pion bien compacte et
aucun affaiblissement de la position
donc dans cette position après kbd7 vous
êtes assez tranquille vous avez forcer
les blancs à jouer le coup F2 F3
puisqueici sinon ils vont perdre le
pion4 et maintenant qu'ils ont joué F3
et bien très simplement vous sortez vos
pièces avec petit rock et une très très
belle position donc ici maintenant on va
faire la la minute du connaisseur pour
détailler cette position qui est un
grand classique a eu plus de 50 parties
jouées dans cette même position un plan
des Noirs c'est de mettre le cavalier en
E5 sachant que les Blancs ne peuvent pas
jouer F4 puisque le P 4 est en pris
donc ça c'est une possibilité pour cela
il faut blinder la case B6 pour éviter
de se prendre des k B6 avec combinaison
ouais et pour blinder la case B6 on joue
généralement tour B8 dame C7 on replace
les pièces comme ça contrôle la ce B6 et
ensuite cavalier E5 et cavalier C4 voilà
les plans pour les Noirs le fou C8 va
aller sur la ce D7 très logiquement pour
garder le contrôle du pion de 6 et avoir
un petit œil sur le cavalier et sur le
cavalier A4 les blancs eux vont tenter
de jouer le pion C et dès que ce pion C
bouge qu' C3 vous le prenez en passant
avec une position tout à fait équilibrée
voilà donc pour cette première partie
qui est une partie très intéressante
pour la théorie on va la revoir
rapidement mais on a un deuxième exemple
qui va nous permettre de revenir sur les
mêmes
coups donc tout de suite à parti juditth
pagard contre Boris gelffound alors
Stéphan je crois que tu es un fan de
Judit pagard ah ou mais tout le monde
est fan de Judit paulgard donc je crois
qu'elle est d'ailleurs tout récemment
rentré dans le dans le club des 20
premiers mondiaux qu'elle avait quitté
un temps et elle est revenue au prier
premier plan Judit palgard donc avec les
Blancs contre Boris gelffond énorme
joueur de nashdorf il a joué ça depuis
qu'il est tout petit donc il la connaît
très bien E4 C5 les premiers coups sont
les mêmes cavalier F3 D6 D4 pion prend
D4 cavalier prend cavalier F6 cavalier
C3 A6 fou C4 bon c'est le fameux coup le
6 petit rock donc là au lieu de fou B3
petit rock mais après B5 ça change on
joue oua çaou ça change pas grand chose
alors dans cette position on vous le
rappelle on ne veut pas jouer fou B 7
pardon on pas jouer fou B7 puisque ça
fablit le pion 6 ouais ça permet fou
prend 6 pas tout de suite pas dans cette
position mais en tout cas les blancs
pourra jouer F4 F5 avec une attaque
énorme contre ce pion B6 donc on joue
fou E7 h dame F3 c'est une tentative on
verra les autres tentatives tout à
l'heure ici là on ne joue vraiment pas
fou B7 puisqu'il y a le sacrifice en 6
ouais parce que maintenant le P G7 n'est
plus défendu donc après que le cavalier
reprend prend le pion G7 avec échec on
joue dame B6 contreattaque sur le C D4
et en même temps sur R5 on a fou B7
qui contre-attaque la dame fou E3 et
maintenant on met la dame sur la case B7
important donc on a résolu le problème
de la tour A8 ouais dans un premier
temps les Blancs jouent dame G3 alors
ici très important il ne faut pas que
les Blancs jouent F4 F5 ça c'est hyper
important on joue donc B4 chasse le
cavalier C3 cavalier A4 et cavalier BD7
ça c'est pour le contrôle de la case B6
puisque si on joue petit ro dans cette
position Stéphane il y a un problème im
a c'est je crois cavalier
B6 que nous allons vérifier tout de
suite cavalier B6 je crois que ce coup
est assez fort puisque sur dame prend B6
il y a cavalier prend E6 ou cavalier F5
au choix ah cavalier F5 qui est pas mal
ou qui attaque la dame et qui menace mat
qui menace mat ou donc tout ça est fort
désagréable donc après cavalier A4 on
joue k BD7 protégeant la ce B6 et en
même temps le pion G7 n'est pas en prise
puisquon l' dit a tour G8 et dame
FR4 donc nous continuons F3 c'est nous
avons forcé les blancs à jouer F3
maintenant nous faisons petit rock et là
il y a un piège puisque votre adversaire
peut être tenté de jouer fou H6 ouais
menace mat menace mat qui perd en ligne
ouais on va voir ça perd de manière
forcée donc là c'est l'occasion pour
vous Stéphane enfin pour vous internaut
de gagner une partie facile ouais ici on
joue cavalier H5 attaque la dame défend
G7 défend G7 et attaque la dame la dame
vient sur la case H3 puisque sur dame G4
nous jouons cavalier d en F6 cavalier en
défense du de cavalier donc extrêmement
puissant on peut on peut vous montrer
cette possibilité d'AM
G4 cavalier d sur la case F6 attaque la
dame la dame doit encore quitter enfin
doit rester dans le clouage justement
pour que les Noirs ne puissent pas
prendre et maintenant il suffit de jouer
par exemple ro H8 qui a l'air de gagner
tout simplement le fou ne peut plus
partir
ouis oui le fou le fou est en prison
voilà donc le Fou est en prise la
première chose cavalier H5 attaque la
dame sur dame G4 c'est pas possible donc
dame H3 contreattaque att sur le
cavalier H5 ouais mais là on prend quand
même le fou dame prend cavalier et
maintenant la petite pointe qui vous
fait marquer le point dame à 7 le coup
souple clouage de cavalier D4 ouais et
menace 5 et menace 5 donc les les blancs
défendent le cavalier et maintenant il
suffit de l'attaquer avec un pion il est
toujours cloué donc il peut plus bouger
pour résumer ce qui s'est passé après
dame à 7 on cloue le cavalier et les
Blancs ne peuvent pas simultanément le
défendre et le déclouer joli joli
parcours de dame alors dame B6 dame B7
dame à 7 c'est un parcours coup de dame
petit parcours efficace petit parcours
efficace voilà donc un piège que vous
pouvez placer à vos adversaire tout à
fait agréable dans cette position Boris
g Jud POLG a continué ça c'est agréable
mais la partie n'a fait aucun doute
après le gain de la pièce cette position
est totalement gagnante pour les Noirs
une partie suivante Stéphane donc qui
est dans un autre une autre variante une
autre thématique une partie du grand
Bobby qui a les blancs qui joue contre
Smith que tu peux peut-être nous
présenter un petit peu sm qui a été
champion du monde en 58 et monsie sansun
doute et qui a été de nouveau finaliste
des candidats contre Kasparov en 81 et
donc 30 ans 20 ans après quoi 20 ans
après donc sm un grand N des échecs des
échecs qui est aujourd'hui assez âgé vil
sm C5 F3 E6 donc c'est un autre ordre de
coup des prend des pr des ça ne commence
pas comme une ndorf vous allez voir
qu'on arrive dans la même position D6
fou C4 fou E7 petit rock
A6 fou B3 B5 F4 donc là voilà le plan le
changement ce n'est plus dam F3 qui est
adopté c'est un autre coup c'est le coup
F4 donc qui est beaucoup plus direct
Stéphane F4 c'est vraiment je vais te
exploser je vais exploser la case 6 je
toi explose donc Bobby Fisher dans son
style très incisif toujours petit rock
calme olympien de Vasil SMI
les blancs ici doivent justifier ce
qu'ils font donc si par exemple il
jouent un coup léger comme dame F3 et
bien nous jouons vraisemblablement
qu'est-ce que nous jouons sur dame F3 et
bien fou B7 probablement fou B7
exactement avec la menace B4 le pion4 en
prise donc une position tout à fait
jouable F5 c'est clairement dans l'idée
des blancs et ici Stéphane il faut
savoir très précisément comment réagir
quand on se prend F5 ouais ben oui oui
par que le joueur qui n'a jamais vu ce
genre de chose est tenté par exemple de
prendre F5 ouais ouais mais ça ça
réveille trop le fou B3 c'est une faute
ça réveille énormément le fou B3 et en
plus ça permet au C D4 deevenenir sur la
case F5 D4 prend
pion très bien très bien placé ensuite
ça donne la case D5 au k C3 ou3 pourra
venir s'installer là bref très mauvaise
réaction sur F5 c'est la prise c'est la
plus mauvaise surtout quand le Fou est
là deuxème réaction envisager ne rien
faire ouais mais là c'est pas possible
on ne peut pas défendre le pion 6 ouais
le P 6 va être pris sinon donc si on
peut le défendre à la limite c'est pas
c'est une solution intermédiaire qui
peut être une solution d'attente mais si
c'est pas possible trème solution jouer
E5 solution qui a l'air catastrophique
et qui le serait vraiment puisque le C
C3 viendrait sur la case des5 très
prochainement pas forcément tout de
suite mais prochainement donc smilov
joue le mal tout de suite même tout de
suite hein il pourrait il pourrait y
aller tout de suite oua il pourrait y
aller tout de suite c'estd si imaginons5
cavalier D5
ou et par exemple sur cavalier
prend pr
cavalier faut faire attention
effectivement ça c'est pas possible il
faut d'abord bouger le cavalier donc B4
non je
pensais
Var fumeuse B4 on chasse d'abord le K3
puisque là sur P prend a c'est bien on
prend le cavalier donc avec une pièce de
plus une pièce de plus c'est synonyme
d'un gain technique cavalier
CE2 pous en
E5 maintenant maintenant que calier ne
peut plus venir sur la case D5
exactement le kc3 est déjà parti il
n'ira donc plus sur la case D5 et donc
tout l'enjeu de cette position il est
très simple est-ce que les Noirs
réussiront à jouer des5 ou pas ou est-ce
qu'ils se feront bloquer et ici smithlov
apporte une touche dans sa réponse
puisque après cavalier F3 il ne prend
pas tout de suite le pion E4 ce qui
serait assez ce qui est possible mais
assez dangereux bah il a dame D5 non fou
D5 oui mais il y a des possibilités de
jouer fou B7 avec dam B6 échac qui
récupère mais on préfère pratiquement
tout le temps jouer fou B7
oui de toute façon le pion est perdu
voilà le pion est perdu et le Fou est
bien placé sur cette diagonale tout à
fait en plus on contrôle bien maintenant
on a plus peur de sur la case 6 puisque
le cavalier D4 n'est plus présent donc
le fou tape sur la case F7 mais oui
c'est quand même bien défendu cette bien
défendu pour l'instant dans cette
position qu'est-ce qu'il faut voir le
fou B3 est fort quand même le fou B3 est
assez fort c'est vrai c'est pour ça
qu'on va essayer de prendre 4 et de
jouer des 5 après pour boucher ce fou
donc k G3 h défense Cali prend4 quand
même cavalier prend fou prend et ici on
peut dire que les noirs sont mieux ouais
mais c'est pas facile à jouer quand même
il faut faire attention surtout contre
ficher mais enfin smithl a fini par
transformer l'essai après dame1 fou
point F3 tour point F3 qui C6 ça c'est
la partie c'est c'est déroulé très bien
pour smiof avec une position solide de
défense faut faire très attention aux
pièces d' blanchees qui coulisse quand
même sur les colonne HG vers le roi noir
mais ici vous pouvez vous défendre une
autre partie dans la même variante et ça
ser une des dernières parties que nous
verrons dans cette émission c'est une
partie donc ouverture totalement
similaire encore le plan avec f4ous all
dérouler coup bien connus assz
rapidementve m coup
petit a pré Jer B5 maintenant F5 encore
une
fois4 toujours chasser le cavalier avant
de jouer5 toujours thématique tentative
de Yvon chou il dit moi je mets le
cavalier sur la case A4 et non pas sur
la case2 pas la cas bon et bien
réfutation d'Anand E5 cavalier E2
maintenant voilà son idée c'est que il
veut peut-être laisser la case F3 libre
pour la tour on sait pas trop quelle est
l'idée d'chou mais en tout cas Anand n'a
pas pris le pion 4 il a bien fait puisqu
a une variante forcée qui donne
l'avantage au blanc il a joué fou B7
tout à fait bien vu dans cette ou
maintenant il y avait fou D5 qui
marchait parce que on peut plus jouer
dam B6 échec exactement c'est une CAV
prend4 cavali G3 C G3 k BD7 il se presse
pas de prendre le pion non il va tout
simplement ne pas le prendre dans cette
partie pour une raison très simple c'est
que le jeu des blancs avec cette
structure là il tourne autour de la case
D5 mais là ils peuvent pas l'utiliser le
cavalier A4 est trop loin on voit pas
comment les blancs peuvent se replacer
pour venir sur cette case D5 ouais
l'autre plan c'est de pousser le pion g
il peut pas mais il peut pas donc dans
cette position stratégiquement les Noirs
ont déjà gagné la partie maintenant il
leur suffit de sortir les pièces
intelligemment c'est ce que fait
évidemment vishmanatananan d'après dame1
A5 protant ouais protge B4 tentative
divvanchou qui ne sert à rien dame C7
dame2 tour FC8 donc vous voyez des coups
simples tout simplement pour jouer cette
position ensuite ça va se jouer avec
peut-être C C5 peut-être fou C6
peut-être fou A6 pour attaquer C4
beaucoup de plans pour les Noirs cette
position est très bonne pourquoi parce
que les Blancs n'ont pas de plan
d'attaque fort dernière partie
Anand Kasparov donc là c'est chaud c'est
une variante forcée très technique on va
vous la
montrer D6 D4 hop A6 fou C4 E66
petit 3 petit F4 B5 dans cette position
donc nous avons vu le coup F5 qui est un
coup et maintenant ici laisser forcé
c'est le coup E4 E5 ouais donc canand
tente E5 contre Kasparov c'est un plan
différent qui n'a absolument rien à voir
puis on prend5 puis on prend cavalier F
en D7 ouais il faut attaquer ce pion
plus vite donc ici il y a pas de
combinaison rien de particulier anant
choisit le coup damage 5 donc on voit
qu'il y a des idées de pression en fait
Stéphane parce qu'on menace de prendre
F7 sans doute avec la tour puis ensuite
jouer fou
prend6 on menace également peut-être
cavalier prend 6 ouais ouais il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de pression il y a
beaucoup de choses sur la case de 6 ou
l'idée de damage 5 c'est bien entendu
que ça défend plus 5 h et là vous avez à
votre disposition et heureusement
d'ailleurs un coup forcé un coup qui
force les événements c'est le coup fou
C5 clouage alors c'est pas mal parce que
c'est bon ça cloue une pièce mais c'est
surtout la pièce qui attaque au 6 ça
cloue une pièce très importante une
pièce qui est donc centralisée qui
attaquit ce pion 6 et en même temps de
la cloué Stéphane autre avantage ça
l'attaque oui ça l'attaque ça c'est pas
mal non plus donc forcer fou E3
maintenant dans cette position donc les
noirs doivent trouver quelques ch chose
et Kasparov à la clé de l'énigme
c'estàdire que si on a rien à faire si
on ne sait pas quoi faire avec les noir
dans cette position le plan des blancs
il est très simple Stan ça va être tour
F4 tour H4 et
voir même tour F1 tour F3 tour G3 bref
c'est ce qu'on appelle monter les tours
à l'attaque ouis c'est très très fort
quand on se retrouve avec deux tours une
dame un cavalier un fou un deème fou
devant le roi faut pas perdre de temps
il faut pas perdre de temps il faut agir
rapidement et vous avez un coup forcé
vous donnez la paire de fou prend des 4
fou prend D4 et cavalier C6 avec gain de
temps gain de temps échange de pièces
donc ça c'est bien ça favorise la
défense et en plus gain de pion parce
que ici on menace de prendre en D4 et
ensuite de jouer dame D6 qui serait tout
à fait désagréable donc il faut retirer
le fou fou E3 et maintenant cavalier C
prend pion E5 avec une position complexe
mais vous avez pris un pion ouais mais
surtout maintenant le cavalier peut
revenir en défense en G6 l'autre
cavalier pour revenir en F6 et on sait
très bien qu'un cavalier en F6 c'est
idéal pour la défense du roi et un pion
de plus c'est juste donc ici vous avez
tous les éléments pour bien vous
défendre pour tenir cette position donc
tout simplement gar kasperov n'a pas
transformer l'essai mais vous vous le
ferez sans doute voilà donc pour cette
variante avec fou C4 Stéphane alors pour
résumer qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire c'est
une position où les noirs doivent jouer
quand même très précis ouais E6 ne pas
jouer le fou B7 trop tôt oui pour éviter
des des sacrifices en E6 et surtout pas
oublier de pas prendre le pion E4 est en
prise trop tôt non plus voilà alors il
faut faire très attention quand on veut
prendre le pion E4 il vaut mieux
l'attaquer que le prendre c'est plus
fort les réactions sur F5 c'est
généralement B4 suivi de5 il faut
d'abord chasser le K3 bref revoyez tout
ça tranquillement jouez les positions en
famille puisqu'elles sont toutes très
intéressantes et on vous donne
rendez-vous donc après l'été puisque là
il y a une petite pause pour tout le
mois d'août on vous donne rendez-vous
pour des nouvelles leçons Stéphane
exactement merci de nous avoir
suivi
[Musique]